there's something that drug dealers do
that you all need to know it's actually
pretty ingenious
so like imagine like if you're a drug
dealer
and the police bust you and they take
your money and they take your product
now you have no way to restart your
business so what drug dealers down south
would do is promote a comedy show
presale tickets take the presale money
buy a brick of cocaine flip the brick
and take the profits and pay the talent
hold the comedy show boom you right back
in the dope game no problems before the
show all I can tell you about what
happens after that is that a gun was
drawn death threats were made and I
probably shouldn't go back to Dothan
Alabama any time soon true story
hey what's up it's Roy Wood jr. and if
you thought last season if this is not
happening was crazy I can't wait to show
you some of the stories we got this year
crazy you might see most of my comments
get their start on the chitlin circuit
in doing black rooms and Def Jam with
the homie Tiffany Haddish
and so that was playing some good music
and I started dancing writing you know
when black people dance white people
surround them to see if they could trap
so I'm dancing my ass up I'm doing the
running man I'm true finish I'm killing
it right I'm doing all the little Will
Smith moves I'm here then I go Tiffany
go Tiffany itself I'm dancing and stuff
and this man comes up to me he's this
really funny looking white man cuz
that's me goes Wow you're an amazing
dancer I'd love for you to work for my
company we do bar mitzvahs and executive
parties you would be phenomenal
here's my card call me and then I went
home to my grandma that's how my grandma
said grandma this weird ass white man
came up to me he gave me his car he want
me to dance at bar mitzvahs and
executive parties and she said girl you
better call that man that's getting
closer to your people and I was like
what are my people are we strippers and
she was like no what do you think
apartments for ears I said I think it's
when you get on the bar you show your
Mitzvah right
[Applause]
[Music]
she's like no no that is not what a Bar
Mitzvah is and she explained it to me
and everything and I was like oh and she
said your daddy is Jewish and I said
really where is he yeah in Jerusalem
because I don't know if there's one
group of people you don't want watching
your ass it's the government Tommy Chong
told us all about the time he got
watched by the DEA the signs were there
you know they had my house under
observation for a year they had my phone
tap they had a helicopter going over my
house they had undercover DEA guys
riding up on their bicycles and you
could tell that you know they didn't
look like bike riders you know they're
like bike riders got a look they know
how to act you know these guys are you
know had to jump off the bike to stop it
you know and then they all gathered up
in front of my house and they're looking
in there and I'm in there making bombs
that's what I do and then smoking pot
and they caught me over 1 times what
kind of plants are those bamboo tube man
but only three arms between them total
I'll let Mike Lawrence
I worked at a fast food restaurant for
seven and a half years because when you
love life life loves you back now I
can't legally say the name of the fast
food restaurant I worked at but I was
never loving it do you think your boss
was a clown mine actually was one so a
lot of crazy people I worked with I
worked with a guy named stumpy who had
one arm it's less sad because he named
himself that but I remember one time
he's like you know how much I get
now that I have one arm and I was like
how much he goes a little
but that's still pretty good legal
prostitution legal drugs and Frank
script Joe whatever you think is going
on in Amsterdam it is and Joachim
booster found an even deeper rabbit hole
yeah I went to Amsterdam we did all the
normal stuff you know we hit all the
museums we smoked all the weed and then
finally sort of like near the end of the
trip I was like okay I've got to do this
I've got to like it live all of my
sexual fantasies out here because I know
it's happening here in Amsterdam so one
night I broke away from the group and I
went to a club called the ring
which is very on the nose you know you
you understand what you're getting from
a club called the ring and gay sex
clubs are like so much fun they are all
like combination spa haunted houses you
know like there's just like mirrors
everywhere a lot of steam like holes
with hands reaching out to grab you you
know we're talking about fights this
season have you been in a fighting from
the 25,000 people and your ex-girlfriend
so you can show though what she's
missing out on Brendan Schaub ass it's
finally the night of the fight MGM Grand
Las Vegas I wish you guys could feel
this 25,000 people MGM Grand
my name is on the marquee you're talking
Floyd Mayweather Mike Tyson Conor
McGregor Evander Holyfield the best of
all time have all won their biggest
fights in this exact arena this was my
time so I hit the crowd they're chanting
my name oh my god it's just like the
movies I get into the Octagon I take one
lap around I look into the crowd I look
in the stands in front row I see my
father like damn it's exactly how I
pictured this it's up pops I look more
into the front row and I see Will Smith
next to him I see Leonardo DiCaprio's
son we're talking a list and he's with
two timepieces around his arm like this
and I'm starstruck I'm like oh my god
are you kidding our DiCaprio Jack from
Titanic this is not Jax hitting
me this is nuts
and the next to him I see my
ex-girlfriend yeah
like well well well can't get enough of
the big man huh
enjoy the show bitch as children we go
through a lot of rites of passage your
first kiss your driver's license puberty
that first dog bite but nothing's more
important than that first buffet
restaurant love buffet restaurants cuz
we was a kid and I could go to a buffet
restaurant that was the first chance
that you get to make your own plate that
was adulthood that was a rite of passage
as a kid when your mom trusts you to
decide what you're gonna eat and you
come back to the table with a broccoli
ice cream burrito
you should go what are you eating you go
I'm grown joy shut up I'm at the buffet
tonight team Tallahassee Florida I get
hired at Golden Corral and one person I
always love talking to I love talking to
this do big mix big mix work the carving
station he was slicing to me and take
some right now there's nobody more
focused in this world than a black man
determined not to go back to jail
cuz that's all big mix talk about big
mix was in the carving station he sliced
some roast beef he putting him
rotisserie chickens on the big steak and
putting them in the machine in the whole
time all the time but I'm telling you
buddy white folks ain't gonna get me I
saw overruled
yo so me you better watch out that your
buddy Travis ain't playing around it
like you answer ain't going back to jail
[Music]